all right [ __ ] out
she's not we're pretty from person
forever I grew up here in LA you're not
and you grow up with both parents with
her I grew up with a live one who's that
my mom and I was your child
I was kind of sheltered and always told
to step aside and it'll be done for me
until you know I had to grow up and
a god isn't quite straight I started to
hold wretches and you know play the
blame game and stuff like that I have
one yet and so it's been a free when you
discover that you work on most women I
was 12
how did that go with your friends in
school I hid it until I was put out of
my house at 16 years old and then I came
out and I been out ever since and I'm 29
swinging 9 at the moment I'm sorry I'm
stuttering and see you there going
straight up again
[Music]
oh you know I've been here for five
years every time I tried to like get
inside I'm always turned down because I
did not take me seriously
I believe I don't know you guys fight
hard being transgender in society
problems in your job or getting a break
for demos
it's just stare into my eyes that thing
gives me as if I'm a joke or I'm you
know in competent I was saying
but you know it's always been something
that I hold on to my conscious I'm
instead of just talking about it to
people and I try to you know hide it but
it started to hurt me more and more and
more as I get older and older and yeah
yeah yeah it like this is hard enough
being transgender and then right
yeah
it kind of it again debt does not work
for me anymore because I've find it to
Aaron I'm not attractive to people after
they get into it
but they see that I can't perform as you
know expect this though it kind of
hinders the whole confidence that I have
towards doing that
because I'm uncomfortable in the whole
act right but it's kind of wrong to be
expected of me so I show it but I don't
act out on it I tried to tell people no
no no and they still you know
persistently so I kind of think get into
it somewhat but I'm into it I tried to
stop or get it open with as soon as
possible too
these person nothing keep they at peace
have you been I've been stabbed here and
my neck right here up staff here and my
leg down step that's about it over the
years so Christo and I'm trying to stop
but then again every time I get up I'm
it's in my face so I do it I tried to
cut back on doing it and I have I have
but it's still there you know so I can't
get over it
just yeah I'm trying to though I'm
trying to yeah my mom is dead so no I
don't have content
and everyone else that they kind of
hated me so no all of them kind of shown
me anything do not like me neither but
you know I still trying to be as
peaceful and calm and cordial as
possible but I'm dealing with a lot of
hatred
a lot of it and I get over it and still
keep to talk to people and do things and
it's hurting me it's hurting right
so I ran all over the negative blah blah
blah blah blah I'm into positive top and
I'm kind of being fake because I hear
all of them talking to me but I need pay
attention to anything that they're
saying because deep down inside I'd be
like okay but this person is the same
person who did this to so I'm holding
grudges towards them just as I did
towards to my mother and I'm trying to
bring all of it but it is hard it's
it's hard to keep them we're good
they that'll still I don't do any of
that to Mike but I do kind of hold a
grudge against people and it I don't
know how to take this steps towards
gaining a good confident strong
confidence and a good life in my future
I hope I can but I'm not Judy thanks for
your vision I was planning on going to
Paris to do an intern shift there but I
would have to stop doing drugs first and
go into a full type of recovery
Bethlem is dashing yeah that's what I
wanted to do
he got good and I'm trying my best I've
got a bit
good and thank you so much